zum ärgernis alles wird teurer schauen
sie auf die preise mail zum beispiel um
fast 17 prozent verteuert und päckchen
butter 44 cent teurer fast 25 prozent
ein kasten bier schon bald drei euro
teurer als der zeit der döner sogar
zumindest hier in berlin bis zu sechs
euro es war eigentlich immer noch ein
schnäppchen und energiekosten müssen wir
gar nicht drüber reden öl bis zu 107
prozent teurer sie alle kennen die
steigerung bei gas also inflation ein
riesenthema für unser portemonnaie
darüber streiten wir jetzt darüber was
der staat eigentlich tun müsst was
arbeitgeber tun müssen in dieser zeit
darüber streiten wir hier im studio mit
gitta connemann der unions
mittelstandsexperte in ihnen herzlich
willkommen wir streiten mit hubert
aiwanger dem stellvertretende
ministerpräsident von bayern
wirtschaftsminister dort und mit jörg
krämer dem chefvolkswirt der commerzbank
ihnen allen herzlich willkommen frau
connemann werden wir ende dieses jahres
mehr armut in deutschland haben ja ein
deutlich denn wenn der staat nicht
reagiert es gibt preiseffekte die auf
die kann keine bundesregierung einfluss
nehmen wie den ukraine krieg oder aber
die ezb politik aber die bundesregierung
unter lässt zurzeit alles um
gerade bürgerinnen und bürger gerade die
leistung
diejenigen die die leistung bringen das
ist entlassen genau und unterlassene
hilfeleistung für wiese es ist eine
unterlassene hilfeleistung dass die
bundesregierung schweigt wegschaut oder
untertaucht herr aiwanger mehr armut
sagt frau connemann aktuell wien wird
das vor allen dingen treffen wer wird am
oder ärmer sein am ende dieses jahres
natürlich vor allem die untere
mittelschicht die sparguthaben
vielleicht einen kleinem ausmaß hatten
die sparguthaben werden aufgezehrt die
paar tausend euro auf der sparkasse die
man vielleicht zur seite gelegt hatte um
für die kinder war es an weihnachten
zurück zu legen und so weiter die werden
weg sein am ende des jahres für die
gestiegenen spritpreise für die
gestiegenen heizkosten für die
gestiegene
lebensmittelpreise oder wer den
handwerker braucht wenn er überhaupt
noch kommt der wird ein mehrfaches
zahlen müssen als in der vergangenheit
und dann wird das konto leer sein es
wird vor allem den unteren mittelstand
treffen er kann gehen wir noch mal kurz
in die welt der zahlen wie schlimm wird
das ihrer auffassung nach ihrer prognose
nach mit der inflation aktuell bei 7,3
prozent wie weit geht es noch auf
das hängt jetzt davon ab wie der krieg
in der ukraine dann weitergeht wie sich
die opel verhält
und da ist natürlich möglich dass die
inflation weiter steigt es kann aber
auch sein dass sie weiter dass sie etwas
zurückgeht aber eins ist klar die
inflation ist gespielt und sind jetzt
noch lange über den zwei prozent liegen
die europäische zentralbank ezb
versprochen hat noch lange was heißt
noch lange also die bundesbank sagt zum
beispiel mindestens 20 24 also müssen
wir tatsächlich so lange mit diesem
teuer schock rechnen
ja ich weiß nicht ob die inflation jetzt
in zwei drei jahren noch so hoch sein
wie jetzt glaube ich eher nicht aber sie
müssen sehen dass das eine eine richtige
inflationswelle ist und ich sehe auch
noch nicht dass die europäische
zentralbank wirklich gegenmaßnahmen
ergriffen hat und insofern ist es
wahrscheinlich dass die inflation im
durchschnitt der kommenden jahr über
zwei prozent geben wird aber das wird
immer gehen mit einem auf und ab in
wellen so haben es ja auch wieder hoch
inflation zeit der siebziger jahre die
inflation ist nichts was wir am strich
gezogen diejenige nach oben gehen das
immer in wellen aber im durchschnitt
dürfte sie den kommenden jahren höher
als die versprochenen zwei prozent
ausfallen herr aiwanger womit rechnen
sie im wirtschaftsministerium auch jetzt
bis mittelfristig also erstmal auch mit
dem überschreiten der zehn-prozent-marke
sogar
jetzt hängt natürlich darf und auch wie
sich der ukraine russland krieg
weiterentwickelt den hatten ja viele
nicht auf dem schirm hatte ja nicht
ehrlicher weise nahezu den
preissteigerungen
ja okay also insofern weiß ich auch
nicht was nächstes und übernächstes jahr
ist und wie lange der krieg dauert aber
natürlich deutet vieles darauf hin dass
sich die inflation auf hohem niveau
einpendeln wird dort weiterhin eine zu
geringe
angebotsvielfalt an rohstoffen energie
auf einen hungrigen markt trifft und
damit werden die preise weiter steigen
und werden weiter hoch bleiben jetzt
können wir nicht einfach alle zuschauern
wo das doch wieder für mehr armut sorgen
wird das haben sie ja gerade auch schon
bestätigt frau konnte man sie haben auch
gesagt das ist im grunde unterlassene
hilfeleistung war es gerade geschieht
bzw
nicht geschieht durch die regierung
jetzt gibt es ja den beschluss eine
einmalzahlung zum beispiel 300 euro was
müsste ihrer auffassung nach geschehen
und tatsächlich jetzt gegenzusteuern bei
denen dies brauchen gegenzusteuern um
die inflation ja abzufedern
auszugleichen entlastung entlastung
entlastung und zwar nicht durch kleine
geschenke der stadt verhält sich zurzeit
wie ein gutsherr der almosen verteilt
oder wie eltern die teenager irgend ein
taschengeld geben sondern er muss
entlasten und zwar schon bei der
erhebung von steuern das kann er
unmittelbar wir haben zurzeit das
phänomen dass viele arbeitgeber ja ihren
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeitern etwas
gutes tun wollen und sagen wir wollen
euch löhne erhöhen damit ihr mehr im
portemonnaie habt das problem an
progressiven steuern ist das problem
dass man rutscht muss in die höhere
schulden und der staat verdient sofort
mit das heißt einkommensteuer runter das
ist das effektivste wirksamste mittel
wir haben das in den letzten jahren
gemacht jetzt taucht olaf scholz der ist
bis dato mitgemacht hat aber auch
christian lindner weg und diesen teuer
schock erleben dann eben alle auch
gerade arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeiten
haben sie es noch konkretisieren also
was müsste der finanzminister ihrer
auffassung nach jetzt tun er müsste den
einkommensteuertarif
anpassen ist überhaupt kein problem das
haben wir in den letzten jahren gemacht
da gab es immer einen entsprechenden
beschluss des deutschen bundestages das
heißt wenn die inflation höher war wurde
der einkommensteuer kommen steuert
dementsprechend angepasst und das wäre
ohne weiteres möglich aber die
bundesregierung schaut weg und ist klar
warum weiss kräftig teuer ist sind
meistens fordern uns die politiker so
lange bis sie dann nicht selber
finanzminister finanzminister sind wir
aber in ihrem zeit muss man
ehrlicherweise sagen was meistens hat er
der cappuccino der dann dadurch
entlastet und trotzdem richtig aber es
war meistens sehr geringe entlastung
würde jetzt richtig heftig ausfallen
herr krämer chefvolkswirt der
commerzbank ist das aus ihrer sicht aus
volkswirtschaftlicher sicht sinnvoll
jetzt ran an die einkommenssteuer die
die menschen darüber echt entlasten wie
frau connemann sagt
ja so richtig der staaten mit an der
höheren inflation durch die
mehrwertsteuer beispielsweise und bald
wenn auch die löhne stärker steigen
konnte es in der tat dazu dass der
mensch in eine höhere steuerklasse nein
gehen und da würde sinn machen den
einkommenssteuertarif anzupassen
allerdings muss man sich einst auch ganz
klar machen wir sind als deutschland ein
nettoimporteur von energie und der
energie teurer wird dann fließt
kaufkraft ab ins ausland deutschland als
ganzes wird ärmer und wir werden eben
nicht verhindern können dass er die
einkommen auch der gesamten deutschland
ag wenn sie so wollen niedriger werden
und ist eine illusion davon auszugehen
dass man ganz deutschland entlasten kann
man kann bestimmte gruppen entlasten der
staat kann was zurückgeben der deutsche
staat an die deutschen bürger durch eine
anpassung des einkommensteuertarifs aber
eine echte breite entlastung ist so
nicht möglich war fand insgesamt wärmer
geworden ist dadurch dass für
importierte inflation es soll für
importierte energie mehr bezahlen muss
und insofern kaufkraft ins ausland
abgeflossen ist herr aiwanger wie stehen
sie zu der wichtigen frage von
steuersenkungen also das was frau
connemann zumindest sagt was man richtig
im portemonnaie spüren würde was auch
vergangene finanzminister gemacht haben
mit dem kalte progression gesetz also
anzupassen an die bestehende inflation
das sollte lindner jetzt auch tun sagt
gitta connemann sind sie dabei
ja natürlich bin ich dabei mich wundert
schon dass die fdp jetzt in führender
position nichts mehr wissen will von
ihrer jahrzehntelangen politik der
steuerentlastungen jetzt werde die
stunde der wahrheit jetzt müsste man
handeln und herr lindner stimmt jetzt
auch in den chor von rot-grün hin dass
die hohen energiepreise ja irgendwo
wahrscheinlich politisch sogar gewollt
sind aus ökologischer ideologie heraus
und man fährt damit gezielt ja viele
betriebe an die wand vom taxifahrer bis
zum spediteur vom busunternehmer bis zum
handwerker wir haben die höchsten
spritpreise in europa deutlich über 2
euro die österreicher sind 30 cent
billiger da muss man schon fragen warum
dreht man jetzt nicht die mehrwertsteuer
schraube nach unten nimmt die
mineralölsteuer jetzt endlich zurück co2
abgabe weg um hier auf breiter front zu
entlasten energiekosten zurück die
energiekosten sind ja die haupttreiber
dieser inflation natürlich sind dann die
energieintensiven betriebe gezwungen
diese hohen preise weiterzugeben und die
kunden das erhöht die handwerkerrechnung
usw genau dort müsste man jetzt mit
steuersenkungen rein aber man nimmt die
höheren steuern gerne mit um die
staatskasse hier zu pudern und habt den
bürgern das geld und treibt die
inflation nach oben also die fdp hat
hier jetzt versorgt das muss man so
sagen also dass wir eine interessante
frage einerseits einkommensteuer runter
sagt gitta connemann ja wann er trägt
mit sie können dass er aus bayern im
übrigen gleich anstoßen über ihren
ministerpräsidenten rhein mit der
bundesratsinitiative wer sofort
möglicher krämer jetzt ist aber auch die
mehrwertsteuersenkung angesprochen von
hubert aiwanger und gleichzeitig die
sorge dass würden die kunden gar nicht
spüren weil es würde gar nicht
weitergegeben von den konzernen die
würden die preise einfach belassen egal
ob die steuer jetzt singt oder nicht ist
die befürchtung gerechtfertigt
in einzelfällen mag es bei minden haben
infekte geben aber wir hatten ja vor
einiger zeit schon mal eine
vorübergehende senkung der
einkommensteuer gehabt und da haben wir
ja auch gesehen dass die preise
daraufhin auf breiter front gefallen
sind also möglich wäre das schon in der
gastronomie
in der gastronomie meinen sie jetzt in
corona zeiten kroner zeit mit einem
halben jahr einen reduzierten satz für
die mehrwertsteuer und wir hatten
daraufhin gesehen dass auch die
inflation zurück gegangen ist also
vermutlich würde in der breite davon die
bevölkerung profitieren und jetzt müssen
wir ehrlicherweise ja auch in der hunde
wir alle müssen es jetzt nicht regeln
wir sind keine finanzminister auch über
ja dann mögliche einsparung sprechen
oder darüber wo das geld herkommen soll
frau connemann wie soll es bezahlt
werden also sie wie soll der
finanzminister wie soll der kanzler dann
die einkommensteuersenkung die sie
fordern bezahlen märz nicht einmal hat
der stadt
rekordeinnahmen weil er bei jeder
preiserhöhung mitverdiene passiert
selbst kassiert ist der größte gewinner
der zeit von energiepreiserhöhungen
spritpreiserhöhung aber eben auch
einkommensteuer die einkommensteuer ist
wichtigste einnahmequelle eines staates
und das heißt jeder der jetzt in eine
höhere steuerklasse rutscht und viele
normalverdiener sind ja schon im spitzen
steuern setzen das heißt der staat freut
sich herr lindner freut sich ja scholz
freut sich und deswegen tauchten sie
auch weg denn zur wahrheit gehört auch
dass die inflations berechnungen von
olaf scholz zum schluss nicht mehr
belastbar waren und dass wir sehr viel
schweigen auch hören ein dröhnendes
schweigen hören leider von herrn scholz
und händler alle reden über inflation
aber diese beiden nicht und das hat
einen grund jetzt reden wir darüber was
der staat tun muss aber lassen sie uns
auch auf die chefs gucken auf die
arbeitgeber herr krämer ist es möglich
dass die arbeitgeber in der jetzigen
zeit komplett die inflation ausgleichen
über jetzt eine lohnsteigerung von ja
aktuell werden das dann 7,3 prozent
also ich sage dass er davor deutschland
als ganzes ist ärmer geworden wenn wir
als nettoimporteur von energie mehr für
energie ins ausland überweisen müssen
und da kann da können die unternehmen
das nicht vollständig ausgleichen
natürlich werden die löhne stärker
steigen das sehen wir ja schon in den
bereichen wo es tarifverhandlungen gibt
im kommenden jahr werden ja in vielen
anderen industrie dann auch in der
breite die löhne neu verhandelt da
werden wir das sehen aber die
unternehmen leiden selber unter den
höheren energiekosten und sie werden
nicht die haushalte
vollständig von den negativen
auswirkungen der höheren inflation
befreien können sonst haben wir am ende
eine lohn preis spirale in den 70er
jahren verteilungskämpfe das wird auch
keiner wichtig ist glaube ich dass es
bisher in diesem gespräch zu kurz
gekommen wir reden immer nur über den
start wir müssen reden über die
europäische zentralbank dann in der
langen sicht ist inflation immer ein
monetäres phänomen ausgelöst von zu viel
geld der zentralbanken und die ezb ist
am 2 sie muss endlich handeln ich glaube
da werden wir uns sind darunter auch
sofort einig nur ist das ja eine
hilflose ist rufen in den wald rein weil
frau lagarde immer davor sitzt und sagt
nee nee war mir nicht machen wir nicht
bleibt alles wie es ist
das mag zwar sein auf der anderen seite
kann hat sich auch die deutsche
bundesregierung et cetera auch muss
diesen punkt hinweisen die wir wissen
die europäische zentralbank ist
unabhängig aber es ändert nichts daran
das ist richtig ist in die wir haben
eine extrem lockere geldpolitik ja ein -
zins gleichzeitig kauft die europäische
zentralbank immer noch staatsanleihen
punkt milliarden jeden monaten die
volkswirtschaft rein die geldpolitik ist
viel viel zu locker und damit besteht
die gefahr dass auch die
inflationserwartungen der bürger die er
diese lockere geldpolitik sehen immer
weiter nach oben gehen und dann wird das
ganze eine selbsterfüllende prophezeiung
das ist ja auch der grund dafür warum
ich eben im durchschnitt der kommenden
jahre eine inflation deutlich über zwei
prozent erwartet weil ich glaube die ezb
ist einfach zu zögerlich also frau
connemann der kanzler müsste jetzt auf
den tisch hauen oder müsste sich einen
termin bei frau lagarde machen und
müsste sagen so vorher jetzt gucken wir
mal nicht nur auf die anderen
europäischen staaten vor allen dingen
auf südeuropäische staaten sondern
gucken auch auf das was hier passiert
was die deutschen im moment an kosten
tragen müssen über die steigenden preise
ihr müsst es regeln über euren hebel bei
der ezb muss der kanzler auf tisch hauen
der kanzler müsste auf den tisch hauen
der kanzler müsste erstmal überhaupt
erscheinen ich weiß gar nicht wo er
zurzeit ist
und dann müsste er auf dem tier schon
erwähnt ist aber nicht tun weil im
grunde nach diese zinspolitik diese
geldflut uns politik der ezb und von
frau lagarde am ende natürlich zu einer
schuldenunion führt und das ist immer
ein ziel auch der sozialdemokratie
gewesen das heißt im prinzip wird dort
jetzt ein ziel
eingenommen erfüllt was sich der kanzler
wünscht das heißt er wird es nicht tun
aber jedenfalls die fdp müsste darauf
dringen aber auch die vermisse ich jetzt
reden wir über die zentralbank was sie
tun kann er aber wir haben über den
staat über den möglichen steuersenker
gesprochen lassen sie uns noch mal über
die chefs über die arbeitgeber sprechen
da sagt gerade herr krämer ist so
wahnsinnig schwierig die haben ja auch
die hohen energiekosten aber die haben
wir alle ja auch als verbraucher der
ganz normale bürger man kann ja nicht
sagen irgendwie unternehmen können jetzt
die löhne sinken und du musst halt
alleine klarkommen mit den steigenden in
die kosten also in welcher verantwortung
stehen jetzt die arbeitgeber ihrer
auffassung nach
also ich bin nach wie vor der
überzeugung dass wir unsere unternehmen
hüten müssen wir ihnen auge apfel seien
wir froh dass sie und so gut durch die
korona krise geführt haben und dass wir
jetzt quasi mit vollbeschäftigung aus
dieser corona krise herausgegangen sind
wir hatten allein in bayern in der
spitze 1,3 millionen menschen in
kurzarbeit bei 13 millionen einwohnern
also zehn prozent waren in kurzarbeit
wären uns die betriebe auf breiter front
weg brauchen vom friseurladen bis zum
handwerker bis zum automobilzulieferer
dann hätten wir heute eine massive
arbeitslosigkeit die würde und sie auch
vorausgesagt uns wundert es ja fast dass
wir weiterhin vollbeschäftigung haben
dass wir weiterhin ein wachstum des
bruttosozialprodukts haben also insofern
bitte hände weg von den unternehmen
nicht nach dem motto your typical chefs
die kassieren wir jetzt mal ab wenn die
nicht mehr wollen oder nicht mehr können
aufgrund der hohen energiepreise
aufgrund der weggebrochenen lieferketten
dann hilft dem arbeitnehmer auch nicht
wenn er fünf prozent lohnt zusatz
versprochen bekommt und jedes morgen
arbeitslos also wichtiger ist dass die
preissteigerung jetzt in den griff
bekommen wird heizöl lebensmittel im
laden sprit
mietkosten dort müssen wir ran aber
bitte jetzt nicht die unternehmer
auffordern sie müssen hier mehr beitrag
leisten ich bin heilfroh dass die so gut
funktionieren jetzt ja doch in den ein
oder anderen branchen frau connemann wo
halten sie das für möglich dass die
löhne jetzt kräftig erhöht werden
es gibt natürlich branchen die die
korona krise die ja erst gerade noch
nicht abgeschlossen ist aber hinter dem
ein oder anderen liegt als gewinner dar
ausgegangen sind wenn ich an den
gesamten bereich der digitalwirtschaft
denke aber es gibt eben auch große
verlierer in folge der korona krise dazu
gehört auch der staatshaushalt wenn ich
an kurzarbeitergeld xetra denke und vor
diesem hintergrund
das prinzip kann nicht sein dass jetzt
die mittelständischen betriebe und 99
prozent der unternehmen in deutschland
sind mittelständler sind die kleinen die
mittleren dass die dem grunde nach das
nichtstun der bundesregierung auffangen
dann wird es sich entwickeln in eine
lohn preis spirale und das ist
tatsächlich tödlich für einen standort
wir haben die auswirkungen gesehen in
den 70er 80er jahren da wollen wir nicht
zurück sondern wir wollen stark bleiben
aber darf muss der staat reagieren
halten sie es für möglich dass es in
einzelnen branchen herr krämer kräftiges
lohnplus geben könnte und in welchen
branchen ist das möglich ist das
bezahlbar auch für die arbeitgeber
ja das klingt immer davon ab wie stark
die unternehmen selber getroffen sind
von höheren energiepreisen und das
beschränkt natürlich dann auch ihren
spielraum die löhne sehr stark an sehen
wir haben selektiv in einzelnen branchen
ja auch mal höheren tarifabschlüssen
gesehen beispielsweise und gastro
gastronomiebereich hier bei uns in
hessen alles in allem aber noch relativ
moderate tarifabschlüsse sie müssen ja
auch sehen dass in diesem jahr nur für
einen drittel aller deutschen neue
tarifverträge geschlossen werden denn
während der zurückliegenden krise
gewerkschaften und unternehmer ist
teilweise sehr lang laufende
tarifverträge geschlossen so dass in
diesem jahr viele bürger nicht in den
genuss eines neuen tarifvertrages mit
höheren löhnen kommen aber im kommenden
jahr denke ich wird das nachgeholt und
dann rechtlich doch mit einem deutlich
stärker steigenden löhnen aber weit
unterhalb der inflationsrate weil mehr
können die unternehmen auch nicht aus
sich herausholt weise hier genauso wie
die bürger auch leiden darunter dass wir
mehr bezahlen müssen für den import in
der